could marvel be planning even more
shocking deaths in their spider-man
franchise keep watching to find out why
they might be
cap had such a beautiful ending in
avengers end game with peggy carter and
if that was tarnished in any way fans
might take to the streets leading up to
avengers end game fans long suspected
that either tony or steve would die with
many assuming there wasn't a world where
both would meet their end all across
social media mcu stands guessed who
would perish out of the two and it
seemed to be split right down the middle
in a popular reddit thread mcu fans were
forced to choose between the two men but
there was no consensus among the dozens
of users who participated it's simple no
one wanted either man to die but for the
story's sake one had to with tony's
death set in stone in the sacred
timeline losing steve as well in the
future would just be too much and
bringing him back only to kill him off
would be even worse just ask star wars
fans
one thing is absolutely certain if they
kill thor we riot with both natasha and
tony six feet under and steve off living
in some other timeline the only
remaining original avengers we have left
are thor hawkeye and the hulk of those
thor is easily the most popular so if he
were to die it would be nothing but a
big bummer it would have to be someone
or something serious to take him out of
course but while that might make for a
great scene we'd really rather avoid it
altogether there's no telling what fate
awaits him in thor love and thunder but
we do know that hemsworth wants to play
the character forever telling this
morning in 2019 i'd play this character
for as long as anyone let me you know
i've as i said i've loved it so much
if we were to list some of the most
badass people in all of the mcu you
better believe okoye is going to be near
the top of that list with no superpowers
the wakandan has proven she's a force to
be reckoned with knocking out her fair
share of outriders in both the battle of
wakanda and the battle of earth she is
fiercely loyal to her home country even
putting it above her love for her
partner in black panther okoye's
dedication to her people and whatever
mission is at hand makes her easy to
root for no matter what film she's in we
know she'll be appearing in black
panther wakanda forever and the untitled
wakanda disney plus series and we hope
she makes it out of the latter alive we
hope t'challa's family and closest
allies make it through each and every
impending battle so they can continue to
honor his legacy
this one should go without saying but
the death of happy hogan would
absolutely crush fans of the mcu he has
been in the universe since day one
appearing in six films as one of tony
stark's best friends and as a mentor to
peter parker happy just has that good
guy quality in him and watching him
almost die in iron man 3 had us wanting
revenge on aldrich killian ourselves it
turns out happy was supposed to die in
the film according to storyboards from
the first script we're not sure why the
change was made opting to have happy
survive the explosion but we're sure
glad they decided to go with a more
positive outcome how the character is
changed by the events of spider-man no
way home remains to be seen but here's
hoping he finally gets a true happy
ending
rocket might be a little bit of a jerk
most of the time but we know it's
because he suffered from quite a
difficult life he definitely has strong
feelings when it comes to those he loves
primarily for groot as we saw him weep
when his friend first died in guardians
of the galaxy um
and then again when groot died the
second time in avengers infinity war if
rockets were to die in an upcoming
project we suspect audiences wouldn't
take it very well to be fair whenever an
animal dies in a movie it always seems
to have a more significant impact on the
viewer than when a human dies but we
don't need any old yeller moments in the
mcu seeing a poor little raccoon albeit
a wisecracking mutated one die on the
big screen would be truly devastating
just take peter quill instead we're
begging you
florence pugh took the mcu by storm
after debuting as elena bulova in black
widow serving as the sister of natasha
romanov the former assassin helped fight
back against the baddies to take down
the red room ultimately coming out
victorious the film wasn't without its
flaws but it was widely accepted that
one of the best things about black widow
was elena thanks to pew's stellar
portrayal from the way she poked fun at
her sister's superhero landing to her
convincing breakdown at the family
reunion elena is one of the more
relatable mcu characters out there and
fans only grew to love her more thanks
to her surprise appearance in the disney
plus series hawkeye which tied
everything together you got so much time
with her
yes i did
someone needs to carry on natasha's
legacy and there is no one better to do
it than her if marvel kills off elena
somewhere down the line it's going to be
one hell of a hit to the mcu fandom
spider-man has always been one of the
most widely loved superheroes and the
massive success of the sam raimi
directed trilogy in the early mid 2000s
is definitely proof of how much fans
always wanted to see the web slinger on
the big screen star tom holland does a
stellar job of portraying the mcu spidey
he brings an innocence to the character
in ways not captured by tobey maguire or
andrew garfield and his naive nature
fits the teenage hero to a t technically
yes we did see peter die in the finale
of avengers infinity war and it was the
biggest gut punch of them all despite
holland being in the mcu a shorter
amount of time compared to other fan
favorites his infinity war death proved
how much audiences have accepted his
version of spider-man putting the
permanent kibosh on tom holland's peter
parker would leave the mcu fandom
reeling for sure
groot made his mcu debut in guardians of
the galaxy and was immediately loved by
all despite only speaking four different
words in the entire film five if you
count his name
groot is fiercely loyal especially to
rocket and he has a ride or die nature
that isn't evident in all marvel film
characters this was evident in his
ultimate sacrifice at the end of the
movie where he creates a cradle out of
his body to save the rest of the
guardians from an otherwise deadly crash
viewers fell for the talking tree in
just two hours and his death in the film
was shocking we had just been introduced
to this new superhero team and losing
one of the members right off the bat was
a bold writing choice luckily we didn't
have to wallow in our grief for too long
as it was revealed in the movie's finale
that a part of his shattered body was
planted and a new group was born while
teenage group tends to be annoyingly
angsty we know that inside he's pure of
heart watching groot suffer a permanent
death would be pretty difficult and
watching other guardians go before
bidding farewell to the beloved tree
might be easier like
say peter quill no that that would be a
better plan i like your plan except it
sucks so let me do the plan and that way
it might be really good
with two solo films and two team-ups
under his belt scott lang has become a
staple in the mcu serving as one of the
sillier characters in the film universe
scott instantly got the fandom behind
him and he's become one of the mcu's
leading stars with characters like tony
stark steve rogers and natasha romanov
out of the game if scott were to die in
the upcoming ant-man and the wasp ponto
mania or another team-up film the mcu
fandom would riot on their computers
it's not so much that killing off
ant-man would devastate moviegoers as
much as saying goodbye to star paul
rudwood his comedy never feels forced
and there is so much more to explore
with the character no more scot means no
more rud in marvel projects and that's
not something we're prepared to handle
just yet
wanda maximoff has one of the most
complex story arcs in all of the mcu as
a matter of fact it doesn't seem like
her arc is even close to being finished
at this point as she has only recently
become the scarlet witch after the
events of one division while it looks
like she might be on the path to
darkness watching wanda die would be
pretty painful we know the true
good-natured wanda is still in there
somewhere we're just hoping light
triumphs over evil in her next few
appearances that's all wanda has had way
too much happen to her in her life from
the death of her parents to the death of
her brother pietro to the many deaths of
vision to the complete breakdown ever
not so happily ever after in westview
the woman needs a break if anyone
deserves a happy ending it's wanda and
that certainly isn't going to happen
with her death that doesn't seem fair
there are awesome mcu characters and
then there are protected all-cost
characters and one of those is mr jimmy
wu first debuting in ant-man and the
wasp jimmy was a funny quirky fbi agent
assigned to scott lang's parole officer
there is something so endearing about
jimmy which was further amplified when
he showed up in westview for one
division he fights for the side of good
and rebels against leadership when he
knows something is afoot the allure of
jimmy wu is similar to that of his
frenemy scott lang as both characters
are played by actors loved by the public
if anyone played jimmy other than
randall park fans across the globe might
have been less likely to fall in love
with the agent throughout the airing of
one division viewers campaigned across
social media to get jimmy his own
spin-off series according to the direct
some redditors even dubbed him the best
new marvel character so if he dies off
in a future phase we can expect some
serious backlash from fans
one of the best moves ever made in the
mcu's casting history was the switch
from terence howard to don cheadle for
the part of colonel james rhodes
sometimes those kinds of actor
replacements can ruin a movie but that
wasn't the case at all here rhodes is
another of tony stark's closest friends
and confidants who always has his back
he's also instrumental in the fight
against thanos and one of the few who
participates in the time heist we've
been through so much with rhodes that
seeing him go down would be difficult to
watch case in point it looked like
rhodes met his end in captain america
civil war after vision accidentally
knocked him out of the sky when he hit
the ground audiences across the world
gasped it was a moment when many mcu
fans realized they cared a hell of a lot
more about the character than they
thought they did it would be tough to
watch that kind of moment again with
rhodes as we need as many people as we
can to carry on the memory of iron man
with cheadle set to return in the
upcoming disney plus series armor wars
we hope nothing but good things are on
the horizon for war machine
we've seen a love interest of spider-man
die on the big screen before and it's
nothing we're interested in going
through again the death of gwen stacy in
the amazing spider-man 2 was a total
shock except to anyone who has ever read
the comics of course and if that type of
twist was delivered twice to spider-man
fans it would be way out of bounds
zendaya does incredible job portraying
mj in the mcu spider-man films and
following the events of spider-man far
from home it would be even more
devastating to lose her sometimes close
friends and love interests are killed
off in films to give the protagonist the
push they need to defeat the big bad but
we're hoping that's not a route the mcu
takes with mj with the talent like
zendaya on your roster it's best to keep
her around as long as possible
it took all of one episode for loki
viewers to fall in love with mobius m
mobius the time variance authority agent
played by the charming owen wilson the
actor had undeniable chemistry with loki
himself tom hiddleston and every scene
involving the duo was pure magic fans
absolutely lost their minds when mobius
seemingly died in episode 4 of the
series after being pruned by judge
rensslayer we had only known him for a
few episodes but the determined yet kind
tva agent became a favorite in no time
thankfully we found out in episode 5
that one doesn't die when they're pruned
but instead transported to the void at
the end of time it's usually a death
sentence but mobius was able to get out
in addition to surviving all the events
of loki which suggests we will see
wilson back in action if we lose mobius
in a future mcu project fans will not go
quietly for weeks the fandom took to
social media to express their love for
the mustache rocking agent with many a
thread on reddit dedicated to the hopes
of seeing mobius on a jet ski in the
future if he does die which he better
not we just hope he has one hell of a
ride on a sidoo before biting the bullet
wong is a force to be reckoned with in
the mcu and we're not quite sure the
sorcerer's full potential has been
revealed just yet when he first debuted
in doctor strange it seemed like wong
would primarily serve as a sidekick to
stephen strange but the last several
years have proven he's his own man long
has shown up in five different mcu
flicks and also has a big role in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness if
wong is killed off it's going to send
some serious waves through fandom the
character is undoubtedly a fan favorite
thanks to his dedication to his craft
and perfectly timed one-liners
wang feels like a security blanket
always there to protect you and make you
feel warm and fuzzy losing wong wouldn't
just be a blow to the fans but the mcu
as a whole especially doctor strange
without wang to keep the sorcerer
supreme in line the ramifications of
losing him could be catastrophic to the
entire mcu
shuri just might be the most intelligent
character in the mcu right now rocket
might give her a run for her money but
with tony stark in the ground and the
hulk constantly switching between forms
though wakandan is one of the brightest
minds on the planet while it's still up
in the air what role she will move into
in black panther wakanda forever shuri
is likely to play a more significant
role in the mcu as a whole the loss of
shuri isn't something audiences would
handle very well especially since she is
the only child of king t'chaka left and
as with okoye it would be pretty
difficult to see the loss of another
major wakandan character shuri has so
much to offer the world and her
superhero friends that her loss would be
devastating on so many levels justifying
her death would be a difficult task for
writers and we're hoping she sticks
around for quite some time
talk about an mcu character who has been
through the ringer bucky barnes aka the
winter soldier has appeared in five
films and one disney plus series serving
as the loyal best friend of steve rogers
despite his hardened exterior bucky has
long been a fan favorite in the mcu who
is one of the most tragic character arcs
in the infinity saga he has persevered
despite being brainwashed by the enemy
and comes full circle and repents for
his past transgressions in the falcon
and the winter soldier some fans on
reddit were bummed out that he didn't
take on the mantle of captain america's
steve rogers passed over his shield but
bucky himself seemed to agree the honor
belonged to sam wilson bucky has an
all-around good heart and fans have only
ever wanted the best for him given his
tragic past with hydra if he were to die
in an upcoming project after the
beautiful closure he had in the falcon
and the winter soldier it would be a
travesty some people just deserve
goodness thrown their way and bucky is
one of them
hawkeye turned out to be one incredible
ride and introduced one of the most fun
and exciting mcu characters of the last
few years hayley steinfeld absolutely
nailed the role of kate bishop a stellar
archer who was inspired by clint barton
when she saw him defending new york from
the chitauri in 2012. her constant
fangirling over clint was perfectly
ironic given how there has always been a
debate amongst mcu fans whether hawkeye
might be the worst avenger kate is a
wonderfully naive character who is still
learning who she is and what are places
in the superhero world this type of
young hero is exactly what the mcu needs
moving forward and taking her out too
soon would be a big hit for the fanbase
there's also much to discover between
kate and elena bulova and fans are
certainly shipping that potential
friendship whose roots were laid in
hawkeye these two have the potential to
be the mcu's next besties so they must
be protected at all costs check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the mcu
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]